- [Reporter] The house of
representatives is gearing
up to elect its new leader,
the speaker of the house.
Democrats lost the majority
in the midterm elections
meaning Republicans will
get to name the next speaker
replacing Nancy Pelosi
- Who House Republicans
choose to be their speaker
will be the person who really sets how
House Republicans work with the Senate
how they're going to
work with the White House
and House Democrats in the next two years.
- [Reporter] But after a
weaker than expected midterms
performance Republicans
don't have that large
of a majority in the house
which could complicate the
process of choosing a speaker.
So here's a look at how
the vote is shaping up
and what's at stake for both parties.
Before the midterms, California Republican
Kevin McCarthy was largely
seen as the clear front runner.
- [Natalie] Kevin McCarthy
has led House Republicans
as the minority leader
for the past four years
and he's done it
with a singular focus on
winning the majority back.
- Number one thing I'm gonna do
as a leader is I'm gonna
listen to all voices
in the conference and we're
gonna do together what is best.
- [Reporter] But after
Republicans fail to deliver
a red wave in the midterms
McCarthy doesn't have the
backing that he was expecting.
- The criticism has come from a handful
of Republicans who have
kind of long held beefs
with this party leader
- [Reporter] And one of those Republicans
with the beef is Arizona
Republican Andy Biggs.
He's also running for speaker
while McCarthy was chosen
by the GOP to be their speaker candidate
in an internal vote in
November, the results
of that vote aren't enough
to win him the gavel.
Here's why.
On January 3rd, House
Republicans are expected to
have a majority of 222 to 212 Democrats.
With one absence to be
elected, a candidate must win
at least 218 votes or the majority
of votes from those present
and voting in the roll call.
But here's where it gets tricky.
Members don't have to vote
for their party's nominated candidate.
They could vote for anyone
even if they aren't serving in the house.
Democrats aren't expected
to vote for McCarthy
and at least five Republicans
have voiced their opposition
to McCarthy in recent days.
- I think it's far too risky
to pick Kevin McCarthy.
I think it's risky to have
someone leading our effort going
into 2024 who vastly
underperformed in 2022.
- So the way the math works
is Kevin McCarthy cannot
lose five votes.
If he has four detractors,
that will get him to 218
but he's got to work to
win some of the other
folks over and make sure
that the folks who haven't
announced how they're voting
are going to be in his camp.
- [Reporter] The opposition
from House Republicans
varies making it difficult
for McCarthy to address every issue.
- Andy Biggs, he's been critical
of Kevin McCarthy's leadership.
Matt Gates has had long time conflicts
with Kevin McCarthy, Ralph Norman.
He's kind of gone back and forth
on how adamant he is in the
opposition to Kevin McCarthy.
- [Reporter] Some Republicans
have said they would
support McCarthy if he commits to changing
some conference rules
including the motion to vacate a chair
which would make it easier for
him to be ousted as speaker.
McCarthy hasn't yet agreed
to back that motion.
- You have a broad swath
of the House Republican
Conference that is backing
Kevin McCarthy, but
because their majority is
so narrow, any handful of
House Republicans can make
Kevin McCarthy's life difficult.
- [Reporter] If McCarthy can't
garner the 218 votes needed
to become speaker, a
few things could happen.
The Clerk of the House
representative Cheryl Johnson
could repeat the vote until
someone gets a majority
but that hasn't happened that often.
The last time the house voted
on multiple ballots for a
speaker vote was in 1923.
- Most Republican
lawmakers will acknowledge
that they think this will
go to multiple ballots.
- [Reporter] If that doesn't
work, they could adjourn
the house essentially
calling a timeout in order
to find a solution whether
that's a different candidate
or twisting the arm of
detractors, in the year ahead.
Republicans are facing a vote
on lifting the debt ceiling
and funding the federal government.
Two historically tough issues
for Republicans who
oppose increased spending.
- Whoever takes this job
if it's Kevin McCarthy or someone else
is going to be setting up
for an even tougher wrangling
of House Republicans in the new Congress.
This is only the first vote.